so let's talk a little bit about your
work I was very pleased to find in one
of the collections of your early work
one of my favorite stories at the time
as a science fiction fan the way of
cross and dragon it's called it won a
couple of awards for you at the tiger
award Hugo Award that's the biggest
achievement the biggest of all you can
get really with the Nebula together and
you have won powers of course many times
that was that's in 1980 I won two yoga
wards that year first time it had ever
been done so that was one of the
highlights of my life that night in
Boston in 1980 I won the way of cross
and Dragon won best short story and I
got up and accepted that award and made
my way back to the seat and then that's
not all that sand Kings won so I got to
get right back up and come back to the
stage that's an experience that few
people have ever got to have and
probably one I'll never have again but
it was it was an exciting moment in my
life you had a thing going on with
Dragons fairly early on in your career
dragons are cool
what makes dragons cool the homes in
dragon cool I don't know what does make
dragons cool I mean as a kid the size of
aliens I also had plastic dinosaurs and
dinosaurs are cool and Dragons are like
dinosaurs with wings and breathing fire
so that just increases the coolness
factor turns it up to 11 and it's
interesting that so many different
cultures on earth have have legends of
dragons you know even Chinese dragons of
course are very different in Western
dragons but still there are certain
similarities to so I I sometimes wonder
if dragons aren't they don't derive from
dinosaurs in some sense you know maybe
our ancestors came across dinosaur bones
in the fields and thought there must
have been dragons and invented these
legends about them may I quote from I
think one of your first published works
a letter in a comic magazine sure affair
yes this is Fantastic Four number 17 a
letter addressed to Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby text on site now fantastic
seventeen was greater than great even
now I sit in awe of it trying to do the
impossible that is to describe it it was
absolutely stupendous the ultimate at
most I cannot fathom how you could fit
so much action into so few pages that
sounds like a description of A Song of
Ice and Fire
like move over Shakespeare's Stanley has
arrived now all comics were great they
were revolutionary at the time I still
look back on what Stanley accomplished
and the characters he created in the
stories you told and he revolutionized
that art form so and made comics what
they are today
so it was pretty pretty amazing I also
unfortunately if you continue to read
that litter use the phrase by gumbo at
one point which of course someone in my
high school found and it was used to
torment me for the next four or five
years you know people would meet me in
the hallway as my gumbo my gumbo
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Belle socialize kit did you have friends
that you could share your passion for
science fiction fantasy horror or the
comics well I had some sure although I
think I was the biggest you know comic
book fan of my group but you know I had
I had friends in grade school and all
that who were into some of the stuff I
was into science fiction shows and chess
and you know that kind of thing it
wasn't as popular as it is today of
course I mean we've we've won you know
in those days it was something that the
freaks and the Nerds and the outcasts
followed though the weird kids but now
we rule the world
attracted you to the genre of fantasy
and science fiction and horror too in
the first place when you set out a
writing you could have written stories
about erectile dysfunction and value at
a text you know mainstream fiction you
know I don't I don't know I mean it my
relationship so that goes back so far
into my childhood I have always been a
voracious reader you know and from comic
books then I moved on to book books and
the first science fiction book I ever
read was Robert a Heinlein's half space
suit will travel one of his juvenile
books that he wrote in the 1950s and
that hooked me and then I started buying
other books taking part of my allowance
and not spending it on comic books but
instead spending it on science fiction
paperbacks it wasn't much fantasy in
those days it was almost all science
fiction in the fifties and sixties what
I did eventually encounter fantasy - I
just love I think it might have been a
reaction to the life that I lived
because you know we didn't have much
money we never went anywhere
I lived on First Street in Bayonne New
Jersey I went to school on Fifth Street
my family didn't even have a car
so my my world was five blocks long
first Street - fifth Street I knew those
I knew that world very well I knew very
little outside of it you know once a
year we would go into New York City for
to see Santa Claus at Macy's and attend
the Christmas show at Radio City Music
Hall and eat in an automat but that was
about it
so but in in books I could go to other
planets I could I could go to all around
the world to you
Shanghai and and China and the jungles
of Africa and and you know Europe and
wherever I want but also to Mars and and
to middle-earth and all these fabulous
places so and I yearned for something
more than the five blocks that I knew in
Bayonne